shrimp goes down for rays at the back
line sneaky is burning down really be
able to kite away with his life he does
jets against the double kill this
hemisphere theme plethora pulled up he
cuts it back as Ray goes down and apex
of [ __ ] Elton is burning them down he
can chase he's going back
are you kidding me Jetson what's up guys
my name is Colin McNeill for the score
eSports the story of Jensen is one of
redemption coming back in 2015 after an
indefinite ban from League of Legends
he's become one of n A's strongest mid
laners with the player formerly known as
incarnation having a hell of a spring
split so far we thought it'd be the
perfect time to bring you the very best
of Jensen - but they've got a respect
rise with a fine thing it's still three
picked up already Jensen shock waves
have been on point rash picks up the
fourth alongside Jensen and universe
player so I definitely want to see some
more back to the hole it's from them is
not binge it's looking for so a great
stuff whatever fits in that's a kill
I didn't think ambition was gonna get
there in time meteos just got the axe
shockwave in the mid lane
I'm feeling pretty confident by figuring
up against them I'm pretty sure we're
gonna body these folks that gives
incarnation a lot of room to walk the
flash-forward not there what a plan yet
but it will get burned down not just yet
Jensen Watson get this yield answer
refer to your life has the Otzi still up
will he go for the killing of elsewhere
the double kill he was right there on
top but they forgot existed something I
always wanted to be was be the best at
what I do so that's what I just really
wanted to do in these ones Jensen
oh-ho he's caught right between the
counter in the wall and he's taken a lot
of damage but forgiving is the one who's
actually caught up and excited he's
gonna get almost blown up to pieces the
ignited still ticking
yeah and I'm wondering when they're
gonna go there's no stopping fun to
throw it in the calling coming out
smoothie trying to rotate it and Jensen
grabs himself a kill
rested maybe they're gonna fight one
thing a solid killer Walter
history
she leaves the company now has an
opening closing to make it happen staff
good plug for that's loaded up Jets they
get it grab the first blood Baker gonna
get arranged for now it's blank who's
alone smoothie
first chanson finally get revenge on
baker knocked down while still having
their own mid to fall back on Kitty's
gets caught and apprehended backwards
fates all two times incarnation while
your compress the front lines and take
him down who he is dropping the one for
one so far shockwave comes in direct
already gone
so you said a six a make that a three
killed cornered here destined there the
one who let about I have for a move out
to give an afro burger here and this one
takes them down just a tip about it out
there one day one stop
seismic shut though they broke up with
the little dead said get hit chillin his
land abundant well I'm not hopping off
fight looks like they're gonna tempered
fate it they pull back for now Adrian
gets killed by Baron great damage as he
was held back by Jensen reign over very
long ago down c9 fighting
impact flashes away intentions for what
he can look at Rick Walker from tension
bow bounces on the left and they almost
know it immediately as he faces away
with his distortion Burt Johnson that I
eat that arrow inside turvy oh yeah
Bad News Bears even worse news lapse
reincarnation ear oh what oh oh the
gravity bail for a second I'm thinking
why are you giving to the kill somebody
take it but the Incarnation plays the
ground will air are gonna get himself
out alive looking for oh just that time
anyway just around the he Bates Phoenix
into the fight and first blood to gent
to the skies didn't do full damage they
may be able to hit impact here each use
and is it a barrier to get the region on
the each beat a few more shots yeah
that's all I need a guardian angel got a
bruiser top laner you've got a bruiser
jungler you've got an a visa for
everybody's getting their worth out of
that one Derrick's are now going to be
caught out because the neat thing that
having a jensen last game having a hit
now return the favor from game number
one three points from elimination he's
gonna dash through this minion he's
gonna attach the wisdom kill him Wesker
is down feathers been called him out an
incarnation says I agree Tencent dodges
and there's not any men on sticks a pop
the heal blocks back to Midland Oh
Jensen full health puts the trap down
start running Kenny dodge cocoon yes
spitting comes he gets sucked out who
he's in the fight we'll need to follow
up with the steel tempest now it's great
all level who will he hit one target
exhaust is up jumps on - Alvis to close
the distance
slightly incarnation
he follows up on to Elvis he's got to
know this is a trick by now
nobody would stay there like that but I
was coming in as well the double bait
and now they can pull a carnation don't
charge the or comes back in Mitch's able
to pick up the Koufax it's time to make
building your champions easier
introducing the score eSports new builds
calculator which allows you to plug in
items and runes to figure out which
builds give you the best stats the new
builds page also gathers information on
what the top players and your favorite
pros are building so you'll be able to
try them out yourself take control of
your champion and try out the new
feature on the score eSports build
website by clicking on the link in the
description below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]